Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je me présente :
je suis professeur à l’INSA
et je suis aussi chercheur.
Et depuis 35 ans,
je fais ma recherche dans le domaine
de l’intelligence artificielle (IA).
Plutôt, non.
En fait, j’ai appris en 2014
que je faisais ma recherche en IA.
Avant, je faisais ma recherche dans le
domaine de l’apprentissage automatique.
Ce n’est pas moi qui ai changé.
Je fais toujours les mêmes choses,
le même type de recherche.
C’est le nom que les gens mettaient
sur ma recherche qui a changé.
Alors, pourquoi je suis passé en 2014
d’apprentissage automatique
en intelligence artificielle ?
De quoi s’agit-il ?
Et comment expliquer
ce changement de nom ?
On peut regarder ce qu’est
l’intelligence artificielle.
Si on demande à Wikipédia, il nous dit :
« L’intelligence artificielle,
c’est l’ensemble des théories
et des techniques mises en œuvre
en vue de réaliser des machines capables
de simuler l’intelligence humaine. »
OK, merci Wikipédia.
L’IA, c’est juste des machines
intelligentes comme des humains.
OK, mais c’est quoi, l’intelligence ?
On redemande à Wikipédia qui nous dit :
« L’intelligence humaine est
caractérisée par plusieurs aptitudes,
surtout cognitives, qui permettent
à l’individu humain d’apprendre,
de former des concepts, de comprendre,
d’appliquer la logique et la raison.
Elle comprend la capacité de reconnaître
des tendances, comprendre des idées,
planifier, résoudre des problèmes,
prendre des décisions. »
Bon, je vous ai perdus là.
En gros, Wikipédia ne sait pas
ce qu’est l’intelligence.
Il dit que l’intelligence,
c’est plein de trucs compliqués
et qu’on ne sait pas bien
définir ça simplement.
La définition, c'est presque
de la philosophie.
J’ai lu récemment
sur un article de Sciences et Vie
qui parlait
des huit formes d’intelligence,
l’intelligence créatrice,
l'intelligence réflexive.
Mais voilà, il n’y en a pas qu’une.
Pour nous, chercheurs, c’est embêtant,
parce que nous, quand on fait
de la recherche en sciences -
on fait de l’informatique -
on a besoin de choses précises,
explicites, voire simplistes,
donc, forcément, un peu réductrices.
Et donc,
face à l’intelligence artificielle,
il y a eu deux écoles de pensée,
deux types de réductions,
qui se sont opposées.
Certains voient les IA -
les Intelligences artificielles -
comme des Monsieur Spock - le voilà.
Pour eux, l’intelligence,
c’est la faculté de raisonner.
Et d’autres voient les IA
comme des padawan
car l’intelligence,
c’est la faculté d’apprendre.
Dit comme ça, on a l’impression
que les deux points de vue
ne sont pas antagonistes,
qu’ils ont l’air plutôt complémentaires.
En fait, ils sont
profondément antagonistes
car la philosophie, la compréhension
de ce qu’est un calcul
représente deux visions
complètement opposées
qui se sont même
scientifiquement combattues.
Alors -
Si on pense que l’intelligence
est la faculté de raisonner,
qu’on pense qu’une IA,
c’est monsieur Spock -
Spock, c’est le gars aux oreilles pointues
dans Star Trek,
un [Vulcain] qui fait tout logiquement.
Quand on parle d’IA,
on est obligé de faire
quelques métaphores de science-fiction,
c’est la règle.
Donc Monsieur Spock, c’est l’IA,
la logique faite programme.
La logique, elle est implacable.
La logique, elle prend des faits,
on les malaxe et on a des conséquences.
Et l’IA, M. Spock, c’est le malaxeur.
C’est une machine hypothético-déductive
qui fait genre « action, réaction »,
comme dans « Les choristes ».
Donc, si penser -
C’est comme si penser -
La vision de ces gens-là, c’est penser,
c’est calculer des symboles
qui ont à la fois une réalité matérielle
et une valeur sémantique
de représentation.
D’un autre côté, si on croit que
l’intelligence est la faculté d’apprendre,
l’IA, c’est des padawan.
Toujours la métaphore science-fiction.
Pour apprendre, il faut un objectif,
quelque chose à apprendre,
et des exemples qui nous montrent ce qu’il
faut faire et ce qu’il ne faut pas faire.
Par exemple, on peut apprendre
à écrire ce qu’on entend,
donc c’est une faculté assez cognitive,
assez intelligente.
Pour ça, il faut trouver plein de sons
associés à des textes.
Et l’IA, c’est l’assimilateur d’exemples.
Ce coup-là, c’est une machine inductive
qui va produire un programme
à partir d’exemples.
L’assimilateur doit être suffisamment
plastique et malléable
pour arriver à extraire de l’information
à partir de ces exemples.
Voir l’IA comme un padawan
apprenant, c’est un peu voir l’IA
comme quelque chose qui va faire émerger
du sens à partir d’observations.
Donc le modèle mathématique derrière,
c’est plus la statistique que la logique.
M. Spock, c’est la logique,
le padawan, lui, va plus travailler
sur les statistiques.
Moi, c’est cette vision-là
qui me parle plus.
C’est pour ça que ma recherche est dans
le domaine de l’apprentissage machine.
Historiquement, l’IA était plus réservée
à l’approche symbolique,
aux M. Spock.
Ce n’était pas un problème pour moi.
L’apprentissage statistique,
ça m’allait tout à fait.
C’était un domaine précis, ça m’allait.
C’est peut-être moins ambitieux,
mais quelque part aussi plus réaliste
que celui de l’intelligence artificielle
de la raison.
Question de goût.
Côté symbolique, on revient aux M. Spock.
Eux, ils ont inventé une IA
a priori imparable dans sa logique :
ce sont les systèmes experts.
On comprend des faits,
on ajoute des règles
et la logique produit des conséquences.
Dans un domaine relativement limité,
par exemple à la cardiologie en médecine,
on demande aux médecins
de donner les règles de la cardiologie,
puis à partir des faits,
on fait du diagnostic.
Donc, ça marche un peu.
Mais si considère un monde ouvert,
on considère plus de malades,
des choses plus compliquées -
je ne parle pas du langage naturel -
alors là, ça ne marche plus.
En fait, la machine est incapable de
comprendre ce qu’un enfant sait déjà,
que quand on lâche un objet, il tombe,
que le feu brûle, des choses évidentes.
C’est le sens commun,
une forme d’intelligence collective
que nous partageons.
En fait, comme disait Minsky,
un célèbre chercheur en IA,
ce que nous, on croit difficile pour
des machines, ça peut être très facile.
Exemple, calculer : les machines
le font bien mieux que nous.
Donc, si être intelligent,
c’est faire mieux que nous,
la machine calcule,
elle fait mieux que nous,
mais on sait bien que le calcul
n’est pas de l’intelligence.
Et d’autre part, ce qui,
pour nous, peut sembler facile,
pour une machine,
peut être très difficile.
Je pense à un enfant :
il met un an pour apprendre à marcher,
deux ans pour parler.
Tâches que les machines
ont beaucoup de mal à faire.
Les M. Spock se sont dit :
« Notre problème,
c’est comprendre le sens commun.
Ce n’est pas grave,
on va appliquer ce qu’on sait faire
pour les systèmes experts au sens commun
et on va essayer de rentrer l’ensemble
des règles qui décrivent le sens commun. »
Ils ont construit un gros projet
aux États-Unis,
où des gens ont travaillé longtemps.
Ils ont travaillé plus de dix ans,
une partie continue à travailler.
Ils ont produit en plus
de 1000 personnes-années,
un système qui gère plus de 10 millions
de règles et d’informations
qui sont censées représenter
le sens commun.
Mais ces règles généraient
plein d’inconsistances.
Donc la nuit, un système automatique
analysait ces inconsistances,
et le lendemain, il fallait les traiter.
Et malgré tous ces efforts,
force est de constater
que cette approche ne marche pas.
On ne peut pas résoudre -
On ne peut pas réduire le sens commun
à un ensemble de règles.
Cela me fait penser à la chanson
de Jacques Brel :
« Laisse-moi devenir l’ombre de ton ombre,
l’ombre de ta main,
l’ombre de ton chien. »
On trouve ça beau et triste.
Mais allez expliquer ça avec des règles,
« l’ombre de ton chien ».
Bonne chance !
Les M. Spock ont dû changer
leur fusil d’épaule
et est arrivé ce qu’on a appelé
l’hiver de l’IA.
C'est une histoire de mode, en fait.
Les gens se sont dit :
« Ça ne marche pas très bien. »
On ne croyait plus tellement
en l’intelligence artificielle.
Mais pendant ce temps-là, les Padawan -
les IA qui cherchaient à apprendre -
ont mûri leur projet.
Ils ont eu l’idée de commencer
par résoudre une tâche particulière.
Ils se sont dit : « Est-on capable
à partir de la photo d’une image
de reconnaître un objet
qu’il y a sur cette image ? »
Je vous montre une photo
de fromage et vous me dites :
« C’est un Pont L’évêque.
Je l’ai bien reconnu. »
Enfin, l’IA Padawan dit ça.
Pour apprendre, on a besoin
de plein d’exemples d’images,
donc on a créé Imagenet.
C’est une base de données
de 1,2 million d’images annotées
de mille différentes catégories d’images.
On trouve des chiens, des chevaux,
mais aussi des fromages, du pain,
des stylos, des bouteilles d’eau,
des ordinateurs, etc.
mille objets différents.
Si on arrive à construire un programme
qui reconnaît mieux que les humains
ces mille différents types d’images,
on pourrait dire qu’on a construit une IA.
Attention, ça serait une intelligence
artificielle, mais très spécifique,
construite spécifiquement
pour résoudre une tâche particulière :
reconnaître un objet sur une image.
Et on y est arrivé.
Le principe de faisabilité d’une
telle IA a été proposé en 2012.
C’était même le 12 octobre 2012
à Florence, lors du workshop sur Imagenet,
pendant la conférence ECCV.
Là, il y a eu une présentation
où des gars venant de Toronto ont démontré
que pour résoudre ce problème,
il suffisait d’utiliser
une technique astucieuse
qui s’appelait les réseaux
de neurones profonds.
Leur idée, c’était de proposer une machine
apprenante constituée de neurones,
élémentaires, tout simples,
plus ou moins connectés entre eux,
et qui permettait d’associer à une image,
en la traitant, une catégorie.
En montrant toutes les images,
on allait régler les paramètres
du réseau de neurones
qui allait ensuite reconnaître
correctement les images,
et mieux que tout le monde.
On venait résoudre
grâce aux réseaux de neurones
un problème sur lequel on butait
depuis le début de l’informatique.
On pensait qu’on pouvait reconnaître
des images, mais sans savoir comment.
Et là, on nous expliquait comment faire.
Fascinés par ces résultats,
les industriels des GAFAM,
bientôt suivis par les BATX,
allaient se lancer corps et âme dans la
recherche sur cette nouvelle technologie,
les réseaux de neurones profonds,
en les utilisant à tort et à travers
pour résoudre tout un tas de problèmes,
genre traduire de la parole en texte,
traduire du français en anglais,
en chinois, tout ce que vous voulez,
analyser, classer les images, reconnaître
les visages, reconnaître les situations,
détecter des contenus non conformes,
et même essayer de discuter
à travers leurs assistants.
Je dis « essayer » car
ça ne marche pas très bien encore.
Ce sont eux, les GAFAM et les BATX,
qui ont programmé que, dorénavant,
c’était ça, la recherche en IA.
En fait, la recherche sur ces problèmes,
cette vision de l’intelligence,
la notion de padawan associée
aux réseaux de neurones qui allaient avec,
c’était leur vision.
Ils pensaient qu’avec ce genre d’outils
et un peu de travail -
« un peu » entre guillemets
parce qu’on n’y est pas -
on pouvait construire une machine
capable de comprendre le sens commun,
construire une IA générique.
C’est à cause de cette promesse
qu’en 2014 -
ça leur a pris deux ans -
mon domaine a changé de nom et que je suis
passé de l’apprentissage machine à l’IA.
Mais est-ce que c’est pour autant
comme ça qu’on va arriver
à créer une véritable IA générale
dotée de sens commun ?
Difficile à voir car toujours en mouvement
est l’avenir, disait maître Yoda.
Il y a peut-être un domaine
qui pourrait nous éclairer,
pour comprendre [la suite],
c’est la voiture autonome,
la voiture qui se conduit toute seule.
Regardons ce qui s’est passé chez Tesla,
un célèbre constructeur américain.
Si vous êtes l’heureux possesseur
d’une Tesla,
vous savez que modulo la modique somme de
10 000$ aux États-Unis, 7 500 € en France,
vous pouvez utiliser
l’autopilote de Tesla.
Ce n’est pas encore 100% automatique,
mais selon Elon Musk,
ça pourrait le devenir.
L’autopilote de Tesla, c’est tout un tas
de fonctionnalités d’aide à la conduite,
comme la navigation semi-autonome sur
les autoroutes, la gestion des bouchons.
Toujours, le conducteur
est censé veiller au grain.
En tout cas, il est responsable
de son véhicule.
Donc, on parle d'aide à la conduite.
Cet autopilote fonctionne notamment
grâce à 48 réseaux de neurones,
48 padawan qui analysent en temps réel
les informations produites
par les sept caméras de la voiture
et les autres capteurs,
les radars et tout cela.
Il y a des choses
qu’ils savent bien gérer,
comme la conduite sur autoroute
par exemple,
et d’autres non.
Par exemple, gérer les ronds-points.
Les Américains s’en moquent,
il n’y a pas de rond-point aux États-Unis.
Mais les gens de Tesla,
ils ont conçu une stratégie pour
améliorer en performance l’autopilote,
faire que le Padawan apprenne
encore et encore, et s’améliore.
Chaque fois qu’une Tesla rencontre un
problème avec son autopilote engagé,
le chauffeur reprend la main.
Et quand le chauffeur reprend la main,
la Tesla, qui est connectée
à sa maison mère,
va renvoyer à la maison mère l’ensemble
des données correspondant à la situation.
Là, des ingénieurs de chez Tesla
vont examiner la situation,
et ces situations,
si elles leur paraissent intéressantes,
de nouvelles choses
que Tesla ne sait pas faire,
ils vont demander à la flotte des Tesla -
je parle des 500 000 Tesla
qui circulent dans le monde -
de leur renvoyer des situations analogues
à celles que la Tesla n’a pas su traiter.
Comme ça, toutes les Tesla
renvoient des informations,
et construisent une base de données
sur cette situation
que la Tesla ne sait pas gérer.
Une fois qu’ils ont assez d’exemples,
ils vont pouvoir adapter les Padawan,
les réseaux de neurones de la Tesla,
à gérer cette nouvelle situation.
Par exemple, ce n’est que récemment,
depuis avril de l’an dernier,
que les Tesla sont capables de gérer
les stops et les feux tricolores.
La release de décembre 2020, par exemple,
leur a permis de gérer
les feux oranges clignotants.
Avant, ils ne savaient pas trop
comment les gérer.
Depuis décembre, la voiture
arrive à gérer correctement.
C’est ça son cycle :
elle s’améliore en permanence.
Ce qui est bien, c’est que Tesla connaît
ses clients et connaît les limites.
Grâce à ce mécanisme d’amélioration,
elle arrive à rendre un meilleur service.
Mais ce qu’on voudrait savoir,
c’est si ce système va permettre
de produire une conduite 100 % autonome.
Les gens de Tesla, dont Elon Musk,
disent que oui
En novembre, il a dit
que c’était pour janvier.
En janvier, il a dit : « Peut-être
le prochain trimestre. »
On ne la voit toujours pas venir.
Le problème, c’est que,
à cause de la variabilité infinie
des situations de conduite,
une voiture à 100% autonome,
elle devrait être dotée d’une certaine
forme de sens commun.
Je ne suis pas sûr que cette voie
d’amélioration choisie par Tesla,
soit le moyen d’y arriver.
On va améliorer la conduite, qui sera
peut-être autonome dans 98-99% des cas,
mais le conducteur devra toujours être là
pour régler ces cas exceptionnels,
même si c’est 1% des cas.
Ce qu’arrivent à faire aujourd’hui
les padawan avec les réseaux de neurones,
c’est s’entraîner à réaliser une tâche
spécifique, reproduire un comportement.
Ça n’est pas véritablement apprendre ;
apprendre, c’est quand même autre chose.
C’est interagir avec un professeur,
acquérir des connaissances à partir
de ce que nous partageons,
c’est-à-dire une certaine
forme de sens commun.
Il faut avoir ce sens commun
pour apprendre.
Pour faire une IA - on dirait un programme
doté de sens commun -
il faudrait trouver un moyen de
réconcilier les M. Spock et les Padawan
et proposer une nouvelle vision de
ce que pourrait être l’intelligence,
A moins que cette vision,
comme celle de l’IA dotée de sens commun,
soit elle-même
une autre impasse réductrice.
Je vous souhaite bon courage
et bon travail
pour essayer de trouver
cette nouvelle méthode.